mein hintergrund sieht irgendwie nicht
so ganz perfekt aus braucht's das besser
und so dekoriert ihr euch hallo leute
ich es wieder mal wanne und es ist 23 30
und was macht eine frau alleine in ihrer
wohnung um 23 30
ihre nägel lackieren natürlich die macht
sich ihre nägel mit einem
professionellen nageldesign sechs leute
das schreit nach einer neuen folge seine
willst du mein weines am start und lädst
du willst und jetzt hier bin ich danach
dieses video zu kommen ja die ein habe
ich schon mal gesehen dass die anna
marias ausprobiert hat sich die nägel
selber zu machen und ich folge auf einem
kanal ja ist symbian entwickelt die
macht aber nicht mehr wirklich nach
videos sie hat man lange videos gemacht
und jetzt macht sie kommen das ist auch
unser kanal
absolute empfehlung die kennen
wahrscheinlich schon aber wenn nicht
sind email artikel super lustige frau
aus kann das auch jetzt auch schon beim
nagel video gesagt ich bin es leid 35
euro für nägel auszugeben und das muss
man ungefähr alle zwei wochen machen das
heißt 70 euro monat für nägel danach ich
mir investiere ich mal 100 euro die
wahrscheinlich nicht zukunft investiert
sind weil ich das nicht kann aber und
dann machen gott das wird richtig gut
obwohl ich sagen muss ich bin eigentlich
naturtalent dafür dinge einfach zu
können ein naturtalent für alle talente
ich weiß ungefähr schon fünf- bis
zehnmal beim nahe studie und weiß
eigentlich den ablauf ich weiß nicht ob
es hier ist es sonst weiß nicht ob sie
ziehen eine liste gibt wie man es macht
ich würde es mir jetzt auch erstmal
nicht auf youtube anschauen ich will
jetzt einfach mal starten
er ist seit live dabei und ich ja sogar
eine kleine kamera das eben auf die
hände schauen können und nicht immer nur
auf mein schönes gesicht
was ist denn in dieser professionellen
nageldesign ist
hier ein pinsel ich habe kein auto fokus
aber leute das ist er
die insel mit dem man gehen drauf machen
kann clean clothes li na ganz wichtig an
nagelknipser und toilettenpapier nein
das ist so papierstücke damit man das da
seht ihr dass ich schon mega movies
melvin primer stift zum auftragen auf
natur nägel nur für gewerbliche
verwendung verursachte zungen darf nicht
in die hände von kindern gelangen
ich habe ein gewerbe das nennt sich
einmal war
[Musik]
das ist so nageldesign stift mit zum
perrin hinten geladen um einen gottes zu
setzen ich haben die auch einen laden
eröffnen
das ist wichtigste ist dass du dich
verlängerungen wir schauen was sie sehen
ganz viele hundert millionen angefallen
hier kommen wir zum herzstück dieser
ganzen geschichte die uv mein nachbar
spielt schon den ganzen abend klavier
und ich dachte mir noch so cool wenn ich
später gibt es auf jeden fall keine
hintergrundgeräusche und dann hat das
nicht mein nachbar um 22 uhr spiele ich
mal richtig dramatischen musik wie
dracula auf den cup ihr okay
die lampe kommt jetzt auch an die seite
[Musik]
die lampe geht automatisch an wenn man
seine hand reinsteckt fangen wir an
zuallererst müssen wir unser nägel
feilen glaube ich und dafür muss man es
weiß ich da muss man die nägel so man
darf nicht so hin und her machen sondern
muss so wisst ihr warum es diese in
einer richtung immer wieder ansetzen wo
wohl abend hinein zu schauen wie man
seine nägel freiheit aber dafür lieben
wir auch dieses format oder ja schön die
schnäbel vorbereiten das mögen die auch
ein name vorbereitet fehlen nur noch 9
das wird eine lange nacht meine damen
herren ok meine nebel sind jetzt ja ich
würde sagen gefällt ich glaube ich gar
nicht so schlecht gemacht ich hab mir
hundert mal in die haut gestochen geht
um der hand da habe ich bin dass meine
chefin sieht würde sagen schritt man
zwar meine nagelhaut nach hinten zu
schieben ein bisschen alles für die
schönheit
freilich ist elf uhr abends das war ja
auch eine gute art von muss man könnte
mir immer die fingernägel machen dabei
mir durch sprechen also wenn ich es
irgendwann mal dann drauf sind jetzt
vorbereitet war das ging schneller als
ich gedacht habe was kommt jetzt kreimer
trainer macht man auch mal beim make-up
als erstes drauf glaubt ihr das ist so
ein alkohol stress mal einfach damit mal
auf meinen fingern mal gucken uns ja das
sieht gut aus es brennt
okay das ist definitiv alkohol
ich habe mir aber naja ok nicht auf die
ok ich muss gar nicht so viel machen ich
muss nur so das verteilen von selbst
okay sind jetzt alkoholisiert der
nächste schritt sind diese
tipps sind die nägel clips dinge die
muss ich jetzt gucken welche auf meinen
nagel passen
okay das wird hier ultra lange dauern es
möglich zu groß mittelfinger ich würde
sagen es passt perfekt ich glaube die
nagelstudio community wird sagen das ist
jetzt so groß kann ich auch bestehen bis
man das so denkt der meine zukünftigen
finger gesten meine damen und herren bis
der sogenannte tipp kleber und diesen
tipp kleber themen wir jetzt auch unser
nagel und dann kleben wir es auf den
dingen frau über das ist eine luftblase
das können wir aber nicht leiden in
unserem nagelstudio nach bern strikt
lasst diese lang wie ein perfekt ab
richtig drüber halten runterdrücken
wunder ohne blutbad und luftblasen ohne
dass blasen luftblase thp nicht dass
diese lege so hübsch wären die sollen
nicht lange währt welt ich habe meine
haut mit dem kleber am ende wird ist
unser handels übrig hier klammer gelinge
möchte ich denn frage auf welchen wegen
klammer bisschen länger machen weil man
ja auch noch feilen muss wie solange die
a leuten die augen auskratzen
ja und jetzt feierlich sie möchte sie
dann möchte ich sie spitz haben ich
glaube ich möchte spitze haben dafür
hätte ich jetzt eine maschine gut
gebrauchen gehören
aber natürlich war ich geizig ich hätte
mir eine atemmaske kaufen sollen wow die
sind wirklich spitz damit kann ich
relativ in der nase popeln speziell sind
schon statement rechte die augen aus
wenn du mich an fällt die versuchung ist
so groß die versuchung so leute ich habe
jetzt spitze nägel oh mein gott
es hat ziemlich lange gedauert muss ich
sagen und jetzt kommen wir wirklich erst
zum lustigen teil wir machen gilt auch
probieren wir mal dieses fiberglas die
hilft ich dich jetzt bin ich echt
aufgeregt pinsel reinen das gel gehe
raus holt so macht es auch hinten auf
den nagel und das so nach vorne ziehen
ich glaube ich
a scheiße ich habe ein bisschen angst
und gele die reagieren ja auch hautnah
auf auch auf led heutzutage und ich
glaub ich hab mir led ketten wie nie so
sicher was gerade die led lampe mit dem
licht mit dem dem 8 wir haben jetzt hier
unser unseren lackierten ersten
lackierten fingernägel
ja ich muss ja nicht nur knapp 60
sekunden warten wir mal ab momentan
läuft gut ich weiß nicht wie lange die
fingernägel aufhalten werden
ich glaube wir kriegen jetzt einmal
leute als ob ich hier irgendwie weiß was
ich tue hier haben wir einen klima und
mit sehen werde ich jetzt einmal diese
die geschichte ab ok oh mein gott leute
ich hab mir selber mangel spitze
fingernägel gemacht jetzt geht es
wirklich ans eingemachte jetzt haben wir
unsere fingernägel gemacht vorbereitet
jetzt kommt die farbe ist also wenn ich
das jetzt verkaufe dann bin ich traurig
weil es jetzt richtig gelaufen
ok wack wie viel von dem farbgebung
drauf man dass man das sieht zumindest
erste mission e
seht ihr das es ist völlig klar geriet
geradeaus es ist relativ eben würde ich
sagen es wundert mich wie die fabel
reagiert also ist eine temperatur farbe
das heißt sie ändert sich je nach
temperatur mal gucken wie lange sich
hier schon
ich mache seit eineinhalb stunden eine
hand
der ist komplett dunkel geworden weil
ich gerade draußen war und darauf
gewartet bis es dunkel wird science bild
also mein fazit ist wenn man glaube ich
ein talent für filigrane sachen hat dann
kann man sich echt gehen alleine zu
hause macht fazit zu temperatur
nagellack ist super ich mache mir jetzt
noch mal die zweite hand und zeigt euch
dann das endergebnis 3000 jahre später
zwischenzeitlich dachte ich dass ich es
nicht hinkriegen werde mit meiner linken
hand meine rechte hand zu machen aber
ich hab es hinbekommen und ich muss
wirklich sagen ich hab gedacht dieses
video wird ein viel größerer fan aber
tatsächlich sind die einfach gut
geworden ist jetzt natürlich auch
geschmackssache wenn man die lange
fingernägel gar nicht mag dann wird man
das ist auch nicht hübsch finden aber
ich bin wirklich stolz und milch
irgendwann 30 euro weil ich jetzt dafür
gezahlt jetzt gehts einmal raus in die
kälte
und wir sind einfach dunkel ich hoffe
euch hat dieses video gefallen wenn ja
dann gibt einen dicken daumen nach oben
mit einem schönen gemachten fingernägel
das ist absolut kein fan video geworden
das ist ein richtig könnte es sogar
tutorial nennen wie macht ihr euch eure
nägel selbst zu hause in einschlägige
tutorials an sich so was was ich hier
mache das war wahrscheinlich alles was
mir die fingernägel irgendwie auch
komisch aus oder gute nacht blase noch
andere videos und musik aus
aber schön sind sie ich habe zwar drei
mal schön investiert aber dafür sind sie
quasi umsonst wenn das nicht alles 100
euro gekostet hätte
jetzt habe ich aber für ganz schön lange
erst mal ich rechne auf jeden fall jetzt
jedes mal 35 euro wenn ich mir die nägel
mache und ich sag euch in einem nach
zwei monaten hat sich das schon komplett
rentiert